It never hurts to plan ahead — especially
when it comes to Hollywood’s biggest flicks!
From long-awaited sequels to an animated musical
reboot, these are the 2025 movies worth making
some room on your calendar for!
Originally intended for release in November
of 2024, Marvel Studios' "Fantastic Four"
reboot has been pushed back to February 14,
2025.
The long-awaited project is set to be one
of the first films of the MCU's Phase 6, which
will also include two "Avengers" films — but
more on that later.
In September of 2022, Deadline reported that
Jeff Kaplan and Ian Springer had been brought
on to write the screenplay for the film, with
Matt Shakman directing.
While Springer and Kaplan haven't had a ton
of high-profile work go up in Hollywood yet,
Shakman is an experienced TV director with
episodes of "Fargo," "Game of Thrones," and
"It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia" on his
resume.
He's worked with Marvel Studios before, having
directed and executive produced the first
Marvel Disney+ series, "WandaVision," in 2021.
Few story details have been released about
the new "Fantastic Four," but as always, there
are some clues as to what fans can expect.
For one, Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige
has suggested that he wants to avoid a traditional
origin story, considering how many times "The
Fantastic Four" has been adapted for the big
screen since the turn of the century.
"This is the story that Kevin wants."
"Okay, then I wanna talk to Kevin."
[laughter]
Popular fancast John Krasinski has already
played a version of Reed Richards in "Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness," but
the actor has stated that he isn't necessarily
planning on returning.
There was a time when the whole point of an
MCU movie was to help build up to a new entry
in "The Avengers" series — but ever since
Iron Man snapped his fingers and turned Thanos
into dust back in 2019, that hasn't been the
case.
By the time "Avengers: The Kang Dynasty" is
released in 2025 — currently scheduled for
May 2 — the MCU will have gone two entire
phases without an entry in "The Avengers" saga.
That should be enough to build plenty of excitement
for the series' fifth installment, but there
are plenty of other reasons to look forward
to it.
"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings"
director Destin Daniel Cretton is set to direct
"The Kang Dynasty," with Jeff Loveness writing
the script.
Loveness, who comes from a background writing
for comedy shows like "Jimmy Kimmel Live!"
and "Rick and Morty," also penned the screenplay
for "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania," which
brings Kang the Conqueror to the MCU for the
first time.
As such, he seems like a perfect choice to
write "Avengers 5," and it's likely that the
Phase 5 film will set up a lot.
As of now, all we know about "The Kang Dynasty"
is that it will star the titular time-traveling
villain, who seems ready to usurp Thanos'
throne as the MCU's scariest antagonist.
The comic run from which the film takes its
title may offer some clues: in it, Kang successfully
takes over the entire world, bringing unparalleled
destruction and terror along the way.
The Avengers will definitely have their hands
full in Phase 6.
"See you soon."
The all-star horror movie team of James Wan,
Jason Blum, and Akela Cooper united to release
"M3GAN" in early 2023 — a surprise hit about
a young girl's robotic companion who turns murderous.
Directed by Gerard Johnstone, the film grossed
nearly $175 million at the global box office
on a budget of just $12 million, sparking
rumors of a sequel that has since been confirmed.
According to Deadline, "M3GAN 2.0" is planned
for release on January 17, 2025.
Original stars Allison Williams and Violet
McGraw are both set to return, with Williams
stepping into a full producer role as well.
In an interview with New Zealand's 1 News,
Johnstone said he's in talks to return as director.
While we don't have any leads on story details
yet, it's not hard to imagine where "M3GAN
2.0" might go.
The first film ends on a victorious, but ominous
note that ensures viewers know that the titular
M3GAN is far from dead.
Given the sci-fi trappings of the franchise,
there are any number of ways she could return
— bigger, scarier, and deadlier.
Cooper returns to pen the script while both
Blum and Wan are set to act as producers,
which means that it's safe to assume that
the sequel will have the same overall feel
as the original.
In an interview with Collider, Wan said he
already has ideas for a "bigger world" for
the series.
Could this be the start of the next hit horror
franchise?
Only time will tell.
In early 2021, fans of "Avatar: The Last Airbender"
rejoiced at the announcement of Avatar Studios,
a new division of Paramount+ and Nickelodeon
fully focused on developing the beloved franchise.
Original series creators Bryan Konietzko and
Michael Dante DiMartino will serve as chief
creative officers for the studio's first animated
film intended for theatrical release.
Over a year later, Nickelodeon teased — through
Avatar Korra voice actor Janet Varney — that
the film would follow "Avatar Aang and his
friends."
In November of 2022, a release date of October
10, 2025, was announced.
No other story details have been confirmed,
but given the recent history of the "Avatar"
franchise, we can assume a few things.
The official comics from Dark Horse take place
in the immediate aftermath of the original
show's finale, and it seems unlikely that
the movie — the franchise's triumphant return
to animation — would simply recycle those
stories.
Plus, the original voice cast is grown up
now, and Zach Tyler Eisen, the actor behind
Aang, doesn't really do voice-over work anymore.
For these reasons, it might make more sense
for the film to follow adult versions of the
"Avatar: The Last Airbender" characters with
either new voice actors or the ones used for
flashbacks in "The Legend of Korra."
"Well, that's just silly.
I don't sound like that!"
"Oh man, this writer's a genius!"
Either way, the film definitely sounds promising.
In addition to Konietzko and DiMartino, longtime
franchise director Lauren Montgomery is helming
the project, and the versatile Australian
animation studio Flying Bark Productions will produce.
Hopefully things go better than the last time
Aang and his friends hit cinemas.
The past few years have been rough for "Star
Wars" on the big screen.
After the lackluster responses to "Solo: A
Star Wars Story" and "Star Wars: The Rise
of Skywalker," Disney officially declared
a "hiatus" on its planned slate of future
films, deciding to focus instead on building
out the franchise on Disney+ instead.
For a time, "Star Wars" was set to return
to theaters in 2023, with Patty Jenkins' "Rogue
Squadron" movie looking like the likely choice.
However, Jenkins' film has been temporarily
derailed, with Lucasfilm president Kathleen
Kennedy telling Vanity Fair in 2022 that it
was undergoing rewrites.
As of now, a "Star Wars" movie is still slated
for release in December of 2025, but it's
hard to predict what it will be.
Numerous projects have been rumored over the
past few years, including potential films
from Taika Waititi, "Stranger Things" producer
Shawn Levy, and "Star Trek Into Darkness"
writer Damon Lindelof.
A story from The Hollywood Reporter in October
of 2022 claimed that Lindelof's film may be
the next one up in 2025 — and that a writer's
room has already assembled at Lucasfilm to
work on ideas.
It's clear that Disney is experimenting with
many different ideas, which makes it hard
to predict what we'll get next.
At the very least, Lucasfilm doesn't seem
to be lacking ideas.
Kennedy told Total Film in 2022 that she wants
to create "a whole new saga," and there have
been reports of both a "Knights of the Old
Republic" project and more movies set in the
sequel era.
Whatever happens, the return of "Star Wars"
to the big screen is an exciting prospect
for fans.
It may feel strange if you grew up watching
"SpongeBob SquarePants" on Nickelodeon, but
the animated undersea comedy franchise is
now nearly as prolific on the big screen as
the small.
The series first made its way to theaters
with 2004's "The SpongeBob SquarePants Movie,"
which carried the same core animation style
as the show.
Over a decade passed before the next big-screen
outing, 2015's "The SpongeBob Movie: Sponge
Out of Water," which became a huge success.
"The SpongeBob Movie: Sponge on the Run,"
followed in 2020, and another film in the
modern 3D style has been announced for May
23, 2025.
Nickelodeon hasn't revealed any real details
of what the story will entail, and with the
franchise now more expansive than ever, the
possibilities are endless.
"SpongeBob SquarePants" has become a major
IP asset for Paramount in the company's modern
hybrid release era, with the movies supplementing
multiple series across both traditional television
and streaming distribution on Paramount+.
It could even be said that the studio is overloaded
with "SpongeBob SquarePants" content, but
it still shows no signs of slowing down.
"Sponge Out of Water" was a box office hit
and received strong reviews, but "Sponge on
the Run" was met with a much more lukewarm
reception a few years later.
"Hey now, buck up!
It's, it's not over yet, SpongeBob!"
"It sure feels over… and crappy!"
It remains to be seen if the third film of
this modern series will continue a decline
or return to the franchise's former peaks.
With some luck, it will be the latter.
"A Quiet Place" has become one of the biggest
surprises in recent movie history, growing
from a one-off horror movie made on a $17
million budget to a blockbuster franchise.
The creative collaboration between real-life
couple John Krasinski and Emily Blunt was
a standout hit, and a spin-off film set before
the events of the original is set for release
in 2024.
Those who want the proper conclusion to the
story of the Abbott family, however, will
have to wait until 2025.
Blunt has been open for some time about the
original story being intended as a trilogy,
which suggests that "A Quiet Place: Part III"
will wrap up the major character arcs that
began in 2018.
In early 2022, Krasinski declared a 2025 release
for the threequel.
Presumably, he will be directing once again.
With a full-on prequel set to release before
"A Quiet Place: Part III" comes out, there
could be a lot of new elements added to the
hit horror saga.
That should make the eventual conclusion even
more exciting — but for now, details are
being kept under wraps.
After a somewhat confused period for the Caped
Crusader's film career following Christopher
Nolan's "The Dark Knight" trilogy, director
Matt Reeves and star Robert Pattinson returned
Bruce Wayne to his former glory with "The
Batman."
The 2022 film received excellent reviews and
performed well at the box office, succeeding
on the merits of its gritty, noir-inspired
tone and stellar production design.
It wasn't long before a proper sequel was
announced, with Pattinson and Reeves both
returning along with "Project Power" writer
Mattson Tomlin on scripting duty.
The film is set to release on October 3, 2025.
"The Batman" has already done an excellent
job of building out a distinct version of
Gotham City, and it's easy to imagine all
kinds of directions in which the sequel could go.
Pattinson himself told Den of Geek in 2022
that he'd be interested in a version of the
popular Court of Owls storyline, while Reeves
has expressed interest in a "grounded version"
of Mr. Freeze.
It's also likely that Barry Keoghan's Joker,
who debuted at the end of "The Batman," could
play a major role.
There's even the possibility that we haven't
yet seen the last of Paul Dano's Riddler.
"And you know…
Gotham loves a comeback story."
Gotham City has a nearly endless trove of
bad guys to pull from, and Reeves has proved
himself a very competent filmmaker with both
"The Batman" and other projects like the latter-day
"Planet of the Apes" movies.
Wherever his team decides to take the story,
it should be exciting to watch.
The Smurfs haven't had the steadiest track
record at the modern box office, with Sony
Pictures' 2010s film series receiving poor
reviews throughout its run.
In 2022, it was announced that Nickelodeon
and Paramount would be putting their own spin
on the classic franchise with an animated
musical film scheduled for release in 2024.
That date was later pushed to February 14,
2025 to make room for "Sonic the Hedgehog 3."
As you might expect, the upcoming reboot is
intended to be a family film with plenty of
cartoon whimsy and musical charm.
Chris Miller has been tapped to direct the
picture — he's quite experienced in the
genre, having previously helmed the DreamWorks
Animation features "Shrek the Third" and "Puss
in Boots."
There's been little in the way of official
casting news, but it seems safe to assume
that the new "Smurfs" film will follow the
modern Hollywood trend of casting an ensemble
of recognizable stars to play the various
roles.
Hopefully, Paramount can finally do the brand
justice and properly relaunch "The Smurfs"
for a new generation.
The "Tron" franchise is one of Disney's oddest.
The original 1982 film wasn't exactly a box
office smash, but it developed a cult appeal
thanks to its groundbreaking CGI effects — a
rare sight at the time.
A sequel, "Tron: Legacy," followed in 2010,
but momentum stalled on any further development
of the franchise.
Now, a third film, currently going by the
name of "Tron: Ares," is finally back on the
books with Jared Leto set to star and Joachim
Rønning directing.
The movie is currently expected on December
19, 2025.
Under Rønning's direction, it could be quite
a spectacle: the filmmaker is no stranger
to the contemporary live-action Disney blockbuster
machine, having previously helmed films like
"Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No
Tales" in 2017 and "Maleficent: Mistress of
Evil" in 2019.
Leto may be less of a sure thing, as he's
developed a reputation for box office bombs
in addition to his questionable on-set behavior.
Regardless, a return to the digital grid of
"Tron" with today's advancements in computer
animation technology is an exciting idea.
The series has always been more about a certain
look and feel than a hard-hitting narrative,
and it's likely that this trend will continue
into the future.
Maybe Disney can even get Daft Punk back together
to do the soundtrack again — but we're not
getting our hopes up that high.
"This is going to be quite a ride."